a solitary silhouette in black a royal
renaissance ruling the runway london
fashion week send off if you will for
her majesty
bright colours and metallics followed a
celebration fit for a queen whose style
inspired british fashion
i think her impact on fashion is color
and handbags
i think i put color first because i
think she always wore great colors in
fact some of these colors in this show
very much reflect by sheer coincidence
uh her sense of color greens yellows
reds bold orange she loves positive
colors and thank you
thank you queen for
wearing such wonderful colors
while the queen always did her own
makeup with the exception of the
christmas speech when a makeup artist
was brought in her distinctive style
helped contribute to her status as an
icon helping her to form the image of
brand britain
please stay in your seats for a special
presentation the queen only attended
london fashion week once in 2018 on the
front row with vogue editor-in-chief
anna winter who described her style as
an iconic uniform suggesting continuity
and tradition
there are few on the world stage who are
as much in the spotlight even fewer who
look as effortlessly stylish as she did
the queen herself joked that if she wore
beige no one would know who she was i've
seen her so many times wearing that sort
of lime green color which not when
people can put off it's a very difficult
color but she always just looked
absolutely stunning with her matching
hat matching umbrella
while the frivolous nature of fashion
might seem out of step right now as king
charles steps into her shoes he follows
in the footsteps of a queen who perhaps
better than anyone understood the power
of image katy spencer sky news